politiques nos motivations et notre
travail j'ai lu tout est son contraire
concernant reconstruire le commun donc
si vous le permettez je vais commencer
depuis le début je suis à la mélodie
j'ai 36 ans je suis ingénieur urbaniste
et j'ai 14 ans d'expérience
professionnelle notamment dans la
conduite de projet complète d'abord chez
un major de la construction et ensuite
dans un établissement public
d'aménagement de premier plan si je
précise cela c'est qu'à lire d'autres
articles nous serions une bande de
jeunes inexpérimentés
à mes côtés le secrétaire de
l'association Johan margliès 36 ans
également est ingénieur nucléaire
enseignant en sciences Po Paris et était
responsable développement durable dans
une collectivité d'Île-de-France enfin
notre trésorier et magistrat à la Cour
des comptes régionales je suis d'origine
marocaine et je suis de culture
musulmane et je suis arrivée en France
il y a 17 ans et naturalisé en 2013 avec
Yohann nous avons partagé une prise de
conscience républicaine au moment des
attentats de 2015
à la lumière de ce que j'ai vécu j'ai vu
se reproduire sous mes yeux les mêmes
mécanismes qui se sont déployés au Maroc
ou tournant des années 2000 l'arrivée
des chaînes satellitaires et notamment
Al Jazeera Ikra qui sont rentrés dans
les foyers j'ai vu la société j'ai vu
mon entourage entrer dans une forme de
rigorisme religieux tout à fait inédit y
compris pour une société conservatrice
musulmane se glissement lent a été
ensuite suivi d'un premier choc celui
des attentats de Casablanca 2003 qui
m'avait particulièrement affecté de mon
point de vue le traitement médiatique de
la question de l'islam en France n'était
pas au niveau des enjeux les Français de
confession musulmane sont assimilés soit
une cinquième colonne soit à des
éternelles mineurs à protéger et le cœur
du problème c'est à dire l'analyse des
mécanismes de pénétration de l'islamisme
dans la société en tant que fait
politique majeur était absent du débat
et disons-le franchement inaudible notre
analyse et que sur les sujets de
l'universalisme et de la laïcité qui
doivent nous rassembler en tant que
nation
était devenu des positions politiques
génératrices de clivage pour nous
l'urgence première était de stopper
l'hémorragie de remettre tout le monde
autour de la table et de recréer du
commun républicain en l'encrant dans les
réalités de la jeunesse alors nous avons
décidé de nous lancer avec humilité dans
ce projet qui ne peut se penser que sur
le temps long 10-15 ans minimum et il
fallait bien démarrer quelque part la
saison 1 était la saison pilote pour
poser les fondations nous avons décidé
de le faire en nous engageant de manière
totalement bénévole sur notre temps
libre en parallèle de nos vies
professionnelles et je tiens à le
rappeler nous ne vivons pas de nos
engagements et les membres de
l'association ne se sont pas versés un
seul euro je souhaitais également
clarifier un point et ses fondamental de
le comprendre pour appréhender nos
productions notre projet répondait au
deuxième objectif qui est je cite
défendre les valeurs républicaines de
liberté de conscience et d'expression
d'égalité entre tous les hommes et entre
toutes les femmes de fraternité de
laïcité qui sont le ciment de la
Concorde et de la cohésion nationale
nous inscrivons donc pleinement dans
l'objectif numéro 2 de l'appel à projet
fond Marianne je tiens également à
préciser que notre projet préexister au
fond notre première rencontre avec le
cipdr a eu lieu après la création
formelle de l'association processus
accéléré de notre côté par le choc a été
pour nous l'assassinat de Samuel Paty et
la confirmation de notre compte de notre
constat sur le rôle des réseaux sociaux
à cette occasion le cipdr a très vite
manifesté de l'enthousiasme vis-à-vis de
notre projet et nous avions le sentiment
à l'époque d'un alignement sur l'état
des lieux et la stratégie à adopter nous
accorder une première subvention de
39000 euros fin 2020 qui nous a permis
de mener les toutes premières actions de
l'association notamment à la création
d'un site vitrines pour le projet nous
avions déjà en mars 2021 un projet
stabilisé qui est-ce qui en détail les
concours les contours d'une plateforme
éditoriale qu'on a appelé commun nous
avons ensuite été en capacité de nous
mobiliser à l'appel à projet et de
proposer un dossier qui visiblement a
convaincu une fois la convention signée
nous avons tout mis en œuvre pour
respecter tous nos engagements nous y
reviendrons très certainement en détail
mais de septembre 2021 à juin 2022 nous
avons produit à des prix très
concurrentiels plus de 10 formats
éditoriaux différents et notamment cette
format visuel 57 vidéos 22h cumulées
est-ce que nous avons parlé de politique
en tant qu'affaire de la cité oui et
nous l'assumons parfaitement le sujet du
commun est éminemment politique dans ce
qu'elle a de plus noble nous l'assumons
depuis la phase de candidature où il
était déjà question de réaction à
l'actualité et d'un fauteuilman c'est à
dire divertissement politique est-ce que
nous avons diffusé des postes partisans
absolument pas et je vais vous dire il
n'y a même pas sur nos pages le petit
poste classique appelant au barrage
républicain à l'entre-deux à
l'entre-deux-tours de la présidentielle
c'est dire notre rigueur sur le sujet de
la neutralité partisane
depuis 6 semaines maintenant nous
subissons avec mon équipe une campagne
de désinformation médiatique et de
harcèlement sur les réseaux sociaux mais
pas seulement des menaces aussi dont une
que je voudrais particulièrement
souligner le CCI émanation du CCIF qui
je le rappelle a été dissout par décret
validé par le Conseil d'État le 24
septembre 2021 a produit une vidéo
contenant les photos les noms les
prénoms de plusieurs membres de
l'association et chroniqueurs pour être
bien sûr qu'on soit bien identifié
malheureusement on sait ce que ce genre
de procédé fait peser comme type de
menaces et face à cela car là nous
parlons bien de notre intégrité physique
et pas uniquement d'un poste d'un
potentiel litige contractuel nous
n'avons reçu aucun soutien de la part du
cipdr au contraire même puisque c'est en
rentrant chez moi le soir du 16 mai
après l'avoir appris en direct que j'ai
découvert une lettre recommandée
demandant un remboursement qui nous a
été adressé quelques jours plus tôt et
plus précisément en date du 12 mai
voilà donc la réponse de l'État qui
entend lutter contre la menace
séparatiste sortir les parapluies à la
première attaque enfin vous m'avez
aimablement monsieur le Président permis
de diffuser une courte vidéo
et je vous en remercie et j'avais à
coeur de montrer avec mon équipe à
célèse ceux qui n'auraient pas eu le
temps de visionner nos productions un
très court échantillon
pour donner une image plus fidèle de
notre démarche je vous remercie
merci madame la Présidente et nous
allons passer tout de suite cette petite
vidéo
dans une société où on tient autant à la
liberté de conscience y compris
à la liberté de croire à des choses qui
ne soient pas consensuelles pour les
autres et en même temps qu'on tient au
savoir universel
je crois que la moindre des choses c'est
de donner les outils aux futurs citoyens
d'articuler ces de se faire
d'après mes calculs
cités
malgré les efforts de quelques cerveaux
biologiques supérieur comme les
philosophes des Lumières ou les grands
humanistes les Homo sapiens n'arriveront
pas à s'unir autour des valeurs
universelles mais peut-être existe-t-il
un espoir
[Musique]
salut toi moi c'est Jason ton nouveau
coach en très bien être pas un vulgaire
coach en bien-être individuel je te
parle d'un coach en super bien-être
collectif
dans lequel de ces pays les élèves
peuvent-ils porter à l'école publique un
objet tranchant au nom de leur religion
États-Unis Canada Russie
réponse le Canada
maintenant le problème que j'ai avec ce
avec ce raisonnement c'est que parler de
l'islam en tant que tel
ne fait pas sens c'est ce qu'on apprend
quand on fait des sciences des religions
ou quand on étudie l'histoire des
religions c'est que une religion c'est
un espace intense une société
votre pâte Rousseau avait bien compris
ce problème pour lui l'être humain est
dans les fers comme il dit mais il
existe des fers auquel on ne peut pas
échapper comme le besoin de nourriture
et des fers auquel on peut échapper
c'est là que ça devient intéressant
parce que vos cerveaux étant ce qu'ils
sont il arrive que les homos sapiens
désirent eux-mêmes s'enchaîner à défaire
les cours de religion longtemps
obligatoire dans les écoles publiques
sont progressivement devenues des
options ils peuvent être remplacés par
des cours de morale et globalement dans
toute l'Europe les cours de religion ou
de morale sont enseignées à l'école
publique
aujourd'hui on va parler de
l'utilisation des réseaux sociaux
peut te dire il y a du boulot si on veut
aider le pays à s'améliorer on est
peut-être pas les pires mais on n'est
pas les meilleurs et moi la deuxième
place ça m'intéresse pas
donc finalement relip boat ce qu'elle
nous dit c'est que se raconter des
histoires c'est ce qui fonde une des
spécificités de notre espèce qu'on est
tous concernés par ça on a tous une
vision de soi du monde et de soi dans le
monde
mais que le problème survient lorsque à
un moment donné on commence à confondre
l'histoire qu'on se raconte avec une
vérité objective
il y a eu beaucoup de polémiques à ce
sujet autour du fait de décoloniser une
institution qui a fait beaucoup
polémique et fondamentalement ce qui est
en jeu c'est pas tant la domination
épistémique et la colonialité du pouvoir
comme le disent les latinos mais c'est
plutôt la représentation jugée
insuffisante des personnes
issues de l'immigration post-coloniale
on va dire non non c'est la laïcité
c'est ça qui prime sauf que derrière
c'est ça qui cause les conflits c'est ça
qui cause le manque de tolérance
est-ce que finalement la définition de
règles communes et finalement n'est pas
la meilleure réponse
vous avez quatre heures
la laïcité est un des meilleurs moyens
qu'on trouvait les primates pour vivre
ensemble mais qu'est-ce que la laïcité
au juste
[Musique]
mediapart révèle qu'une autre
association nommée reconstruire le
commun a également été bénéficiaire de
plus de 300.000 euros du fond Marianne
cette association au lieu de remplir son
objectif de promotion de valeur de la
République a produit du contenu
audiovisuel visant à critiquer les
opposants de Macron durant les
présidentielles
[Musique]
bien merci madame la Présidente merci de
nous avoir ça permet à tous les
collègues de revoir quelques images des
visios et des vidéos qui ont été
produites par vous-même qui montre
d'ailleurs
dans comment dire la manière dont ça a
été filmé une certaine qualité donc
d'images de lumière etc et qui finit sur
un point qui est un point polémique qui
est le point par lequel vous avez fini
concernant la période des campagnes
électorales c'est le seul point que nous
n'aborderons pas aujourd'hui il relève
aujourd'hui vous le savez d'une plainte
et donc du parquet national financier
donc nous n'irons pas sur la question de
savoir si
sont des images qui
correspondaient à la période
électorale etc etc bon c'est un sujet
qui ne sera pas traité aujourd'hui nous
en montrerons évidemment nous aussi
quelques extraits pour que on le voit
mais par contre sur la question de
savoir si
s'il y a quelques quelques fautes là
dessus ça relève du PNF de le dire
éventuellement en tout cas de la plaine
pénale et certainement pas de cette
commission d'enquête pour que les choses
soient bien claires
très bien alors je vais je vais démarrer
par des questions très générales vous
les avez un peu ouverte d'ailleurs même
la présidente dès le départ donc
peut-être vous trouverez dans mes
questionnements que vous avez peut-être
déjà un peu répondu mais vous le
reprendrez si vous voulez vous voulez
bien
d'abord sur donc vous avez dit quelques
mots sur la création de votre
association
peut-être rappeler donc en quelques mots
vos objectifs et vos projets précis si
je puis dire derrière les objectifs
généraux que vous avez présenté déjà
vous pouvez les reprendre mais derrière
vous le voyez comment au moment où vous
créez votre association on n'est pas
encore là dans une relation LCI PDR ou
alors si peut-être c'est un point qu'on
voudrait savoir c'est à dire s'il y a
préalablement même à la création de
votre association s'il y a déjà un
contact avec le préfet Gravel avec
Cyprien de manière générale qui fait que
finalement votre association se crée
mais suite à ce premier contact enfin
dans quel ordre les choses se font
très bien alors je vais vous répondre il
y a une partie de votre question qui a
été abordée très rapidement dans le
cadre du propos introductif et donc avec
ce que je disais avec Yoann on
a commencé à s'intéresser à ces
questions de manière très sérieuse à
partir de 2015 et ensemble voilà on a
fait de la veille sur sur les réseaux
sociaux on a rencontré plein de
personnes qui étaient actives de manière
différente en ligne principalement
et notre constat en fait à partir de
2018-2019-2020 c'était un constat que la
jeunesse est imperméable au discours
républicain institutionnel
les jeunes quand il s'agit de ces
problématiques sur les réseaux sociaux
il s'intéresse principalement à des
récits identitaires que ce soit des
récits de droite
par exemple la France chrétienne les
blancs le grand remplacement ou des
récits
identitaires de gauche avec une
valorisation des identités etc et
ces mouvements
identitaires ont 10-15 ans d'avance sur
nous ils sont ils sont sur les réseaux
sociaux depuis le début et ils ont su
adapter leur discours au code à ce qui
peut intéresser la jeunesse et en
parallèle de ça on a un discours
républicain qui existe qui nous
structure qui nous a toujours structurés
et en tant que nation
mais qui a raté ce
changement de de
média passé de la presse écrite on est
passé de la presse écrite la télé ou à
Internet et aux réseaux sociaux
et donc on a continué un peu notre notre
réflexion et on s'était aperçu aussi que
le milieu laïque en tout cas ceux qui
sont le plus actif sur ces questions là
la moyenne d'âge était plutôt autour de
45 ans et que la façon avec laquelle les
discours étaient portés c'était c'était
ça restait des concepts assez
inaccessibles assez abstrait et pas
suffisamment ancré dans ce qui intéresse
réellement la jeunesse parce que la
jeunesse française pour moi elle est
elle est engagée mais elle est engagée
sur les questions de justice sociale
elle est engagée sur les questions du
climat elle est engagée sur la question
des discriminations et voilà République
laïcité ça
les intéresse pas plus que ça donc à
partir de ce constat-là c'est à dire un
récit républicain abstrait un faux ces
générationnel au sein du milieu laïque
on s'est dit il fallait faire quelque
chose donc on a commencé à réfléchir à
comment adapter pardon comment adapter
le discours républicain au code de
l'époque
qu'on avait dans l'idée de lancer une
association déjà en 2020 et on avait une
première version même des des statuts
qui datent de début octobre 2020 puis
arrivé
l'assassinat de Samuel Paty qui nous a
vraiment vraiment bouleversé et là on a
accéléré voilà les ce qui était dans les
brouillons a été a été validé et puis on
a déposé
nos statuts en préfecture le 29 octobre
avec le cipdr le cipdr m'a contacté une
première fois par mail
enfin octobre également
suite à une recommandation
d'un universitaire reconnu sur ces
questions là et à qui j'avais déjà
présenté le projet et donc j'ai
rencontré le secrétaire général pour la
première fois en novembre 2021 2020
pardon novembre 2020 donc c'était bien
après la la création officielle de
l'association
donc on s'est rencontrés on a je lui ai
présenté le projet notre idée et puis
ils avaient l'air vraiment enthousiaste
que
des jeunes avec des profils
qui sont capables quand même de gérer la
complexité
s'intéresse à ces questions et puis il y
avait aussi une question
peut-être d'image c'est à dire
Yoann et moi nous sommes un juif et une
musulmane ça fait un peu
scénario de films français mais
on s'est rendu compte en fait tous les
deux que ce qui nous permettait de
d'être ami c'était
l'article 1 de la Constitution et que
dans d'autres pays
y compris dans le pays d'où je viens
notre amitié aurait été peut-être
impossible ou en tout cas distante
donc le cipdr nous a
financé une première fois 39000 euros et
je tiens à préciser que il a financé des
actions précises
il a financé le lancement de notre site
internet et il a financé aussi tout le
travail d'études préliminaire de
conception de la plateforme éditoriale
commun
donc ça c'était c'était la première la
première subvention
ensuite est-ce que vous voulez que je
continue
on va on va poursuivre mais cette
première subvention de 39000 euros donc
en réalité bon
elle est de 2020 comme vous l'indiquez
en réalité elle devient 2021 pour dire
les hommes administrative on peut pas
engager de fond en tout cas où les payer
à partir de cette date donc ça devient
de 2000 du début 2021 et en face de ça
donc il y a un certain nombre d'actions
que vous venez d'indiquer que vous
justifiez et qui permettent le le
paiement de cette opération alors vous
avez vous avez indiqué de 2015 à la
création de l'association
bon il y a beaucoup de gens qui
s'intéressent à ces questions là bien
entendu on a on a même tous des noms en
tête des gens qui sont apparus plus que
d'autres si je puis dire mais vous avez
ce contact dans ce dans dans un milieu
qu'on on s'entend tous on peut tous
s'entendre sur l'idée que c'est un petit
milieu si je puis dire qui intervient
sur ces sujets qui est présent sur ces
sujets je veux dire petit par le nombre
évidemment vous l'avez vous l'avez
compris petit Parlement et le préfet
Gravel quand il quand il parle de
reconstruire le commun il dit que en
gros il est en partie issu de un
collectif qui s'appelle on vous voit un
collectif qui a d'ailleurs comment dire
fait l'objet de débat sur ces pratiques
on va pas plus loin
est-ce que c'est le cas est-ce que vous
considérez que vous êtes issu de où vous
voir
alors vous le diriez pas comme ça pour
pour cette question c'est vrai que le
collectif on vous voit a suscité
beaucoup de fantasmes sur sur sa réalité
et d'ailleurs même au sein du cipdr qui
dit qu'on est issu de ce collectif
mais pour moi on vous voit c'est un
c'est un collectif informel sur Internet
totalement amateur qui à l'époque en
2020 c'était intéressé on va dire à la
veille sur les candidats aux municipales
qui jouaient la carte du communautarisme
et tout parti confondu
nous notre projet avec Yohan
il a enfin voilà je vous ai expliqué sa
genèse il n'a rien à voir avec cette
démarche il n'est pas dans la même
temporalité il ne vise pas les mêmes
objectifs
il n'a pas besoin des mêmes moyens alors
après c'est vrai que il y a eu des des
personnes de ce collectif qui se sont
emballés pour notre projet à titre
individuel parce que eux ils étaient sur
le volet réaction
riposte un peu un peu pushi un peu pushi
et nous on était vraiment dans le
discours et et je tiens à le rappeler
c'est quelque chose d'important
moi je suis très mal à l'aise avec la
question de la notion de contrediscours
pour moi le fait de dire contre discours
républicain c'est déjà c'est déjà avoué
que on a perdu en fait c'est déjà
se positionner en réaction nous notre
conviction c'est que le discours
républicain c'est le discours et il
suffit pour nous juste de le remettre au
goût du jour pour que il puisse exister
être transmis dans les conditions de
transmission de ce début de siècle vous
diriez que vous essayez d'avoir un
discours plutôt positif tout à fait
plutôt qu'un discours en réaction
apparaître
un peu noir
et comment dire un peu moralisateur tout
à fait nous on est vraiment sur quelque
chose de positif mais positif ne veut
pas dire consensuel c'est important
c'est important parce que on sait
toujours dit que en fait il fallait
aborder les questions qui fâchent il
fallait aborder la question des
religions il fallait aborder la question
de la laïcité et de l'universalisme
comme je l'ai dit en proposant
introductif qui nous structure mais que
aujourd'hui sont des lignes de fracture
au sein de la jeunesse donc il faut
partir de ce de ce constat là et nous on
s'est dit il faut déjà il faut déjà se
remettre autour de la table et pouvoir
en parler c'est le préalable vous avez
vous avez donc vos connaissez ce
milieu-là depuis 2015 peut-être même
avant mais en tout cas de manière un peu
plus un peu plus forte vous nous dites à
partir 2015 mais des associations des
associations on va dire pour rester dans
le milieu associatif pur qui sont sur ce
sur ce thème d'ailleurs vous vous les
connaissez elles ont fait partie pour la
plupart du fond Marianne quelque part
donc il y en a quelques-unes de plus
importantes que d'autres on va dire par
leur volume d'action etc donc qui sont
très repérables vous n'y avez pas trouvé
vous êtes pas dit comment dire voilà je
rentre dans des associations existantes
je m'y retrouve qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
que vous n'y retrouviez pas ou en tout
cas en quoi vous considériez que votre
proposition était innovante ou comment
dire différentes en tout cas alors je
vais vous répondre sur cette question
alors moi je n'ai jamais été engagé
avant avant
l'association reconstruire le commun je
n'ai jamais adhéré un parti politique je
n'ai jamais adhéré à une association
donc c'est un monde
que je connais mais
qui n'est pas le mien
et quand on a commencé à réfléchir à
notre projet bien sûr on s'était enfin
la première réaction on n'a jamais été
on va partir de zéro mais ce qu'on a vu
dans cet écosystème ne nous
correspondait pas et on savait que de
toute façon on
allait être
parce que la plupart de ces de ces
associations est-ce qu'elles font c'est
très bien mais c'est parce qu'on fait
nous c'est vraiment de
porter des messages
consensuels sympathique et nous on notre
travail c'était vraiment de d'aller
taper là où ça fait mal
et en essayant de le faire quand même
avec légèreté des passionnés de débat
apaisés
en utilisant de l'humour et plein
d'autres plein d'autres mécaniques mais
le fond quand même c'était de venir
voilà
taper là où ça fait mal tout simplement
ok merci
ce premier projet on reste sur le
premier projet
une dernière question il était évalué à
70 000 euros dont 39000 euros d'aide
est-ce que c'est bien ce qui s'est passé
c'est bien un projet de 70 000 euros qui
a été réalisé
et si oui
d'où vient le reste si je puis dire
autant que vous puissiez me le dire ce
que je veux dire par là fonds publics
fonds privés quoi voilà pas nominatif
je vous répondrai à cette question en
fait sur le sur la première subvention
et la première demande et y compris la
deuxième demande on nous demande un
budget prévisionnel donc sur le budget
prévisionnel nous on a inscrit bien sûr
la prévision de la subvention de 39000
euros et on espérait
attirer d'autres types de fonds et
notamment des fonds privés
ça n'a pas été le cas pour plein de
raisons la première c'est que
le sujet qu'on traite reste quand même
un sujet d'intérêt général très régalien
et les mécènes privées globalement
s'intéressent à voilà elle s'intéresse à
la préservation de l'environnement à
l'égalité des chances il s'intéresse à
l'inclusion sociale donc on n'était pas
tout à fait dans dans ce que recherchait
des fondations pour pour
financer des actions associatives
donc voilà nous on a on sait pas
découragé on a quand même tapé à
plusieurs portes on a rencontré plein de
gens qui trouvaient notre démarche très
intéressante mais ça n'a pas abouti bien
sûr ça n'a pas abouti à la conclusion de
partenariat ou de financement
modeste
tout le monde le regarde à l'aune de ces
ressources éventuellement enfin bon qui
est classique on va dire d'une
subvention à des associations
dans la presse d'ailleurs monsieur
Gravel avait parlé même de subventions
de d'une aide au démarrage presque donc
il avait indiqué ainsi les choses il n'a
pas dit exactement dans les mêmes termes
lors de son audition je reprends mon
propos qui a été qui est paru bon mais
on voit on voit un peu l'idée mais donc
c'est bien avec ces 39000 euros point
que vous en effet l'intégralité du
projet en question quoi sur la première
partie du projet tout à fait la première
partie le site etc exactement voilà ok
merci
enfin
toujours de questions un peu général
monsieur Gravel nous indiquer que
c'était
39000 euros pardon la première avait été
je le cite conditionné à l'absence de
tous messages de nature politique
est-ce que vous avez entendu ça est-ce
que vous pouvez nous dire comment cette
condition est-elle été formalisée est-ce
qu'elle était à l'oral dans une
discussion orale si elle a eu lieu et ou
d'un ou de manière écrite peut-être dans
le
la notification qui vous a été faite où
est-ce que ça vous en plus comment vous
l'avez perçu d'abord alors j'ai écouté
avec attention l'audition de du
secrétaire général et il avait parlé
d'une condition sinequanone il a utilisé
vraiment ce terme conditions sinequanone
pour moi une condition sinequanone doit
avoir une traduction au niveau du
contrat
il n'y a pas dans dans les conventions
qu'on a signé il n'y a pas de condition
lié à notre ligne éditoriale dans sa
globalité c'est pas uniquement sur les
questions qui nous intéressent
aujourd'hui mais nous
dans les deux conventions que ce soit la
première ou celle du fond Marianne qui
sont à peu près les mêmes c'est des
conventions type
la plupart des des articles sont liés
plutôt au bon suivi
administratifs et et on a pas eu de
d'objectifs on va dire métrique précis
et on n'a pas eu de de
limitation en tout cas écrite sur sur
ces questions mais au-delà au-delà de la
convention dont on peut comprendre que
c'est difficile à écrire de toute façon
mais est-ce qu'il y a eu quand même un
élément dans votre conversation qui
était une recommandation on va dire
alors dans notre conversation
je pense que ça ce qu'il a ce que j'ai
compris en tout cas
c'est parce que dans notre association
beaucoup de membres ont un passé ont un
passé militant ils sont soit dans des
parties voilà quand ils ont des
convictions ils ont des convictions ils
ont des positions qui sont tranchées et
je pense que que ça crainte c'était que
ça déteigne sur sur le projet alors nous
on a toujours été sur
voilà les gens ont des convictions oui
on va y venir mais simplement un
factuellement est-ce qui vous en a parlé
ou non est-ce que ça fait l'objet d'un
échange alors vous me dites pas écrit il
y a pas d'écrit mais un échange de
confiance on va dire discussion libre en
vous disant faites attention sur le truc
oui non il nous a jamais interdit de
faire des contenus politiques très bien
merci nous avons poursuivre donc nous
allons rentrer plus précisément sur
l'appel à projet pour Marianne
oui merci madame la Présidente donc vous
avez évoqué votre premier projet
la naissance la création de votre
association
comment
comment apprenez-vous la connaissance de
l'appel à projet qui touche le fond
Marianne et avez-vous on a vu
connaissance avant comment ça s'est
passé concrètement alors nous on était
du fait de la première subvention on
était en contact avec le cipdr et donc
on travaillait sur sur les nos premières
actions et on avait une réunion
d'étapes le 12 avril 2021 où on a
présenté ce que je disais en proposant
introductif les contours de de la
plateforme
et suite à cet échange ce que j'avais
compris c'est que c'est que le cipdr
envisagé de de poursuivre son soutien
parce que ça première on va dire son
premier soutien nous a lui a montré
qu'on était capable de s'entourer des
compétences nécessaires qu'on était
capable d'avoir de déployer quelque
chose qui soit
qui rentre dans les clous budgétaires et
dans les clous du timing
et suite à cet échange j'ai reçu un mail
le lendemain
[Musique]
pour me dire suite le 13 suite à votre
échange avec le préfet
nous serions intéressés par une demande
de vous pouvez soumettre une demande de
subvention voilà moi c'était dans la
continuité des échanges et on trouvait
ça super et puis
après ce mail là il me semble j'ai reçu
un coup de fil avant avant l'annonce
officielle que j'ai interprété comme par
le cpdr comme une identification des
potentiels candidats et on nous a dit en
très peu de mots on nous a dit voilà il
y a il y a un appel à projet qui va
sortir votre votre projet rentre dans
dans les conditions on aimerait bien que
vous répondiez merci quoi
et puis après ben nous on est souvent on
est très très présent sur les réseaux
sociaux on est très présent
et on suit beaucoup tout ce qui concerne
ces sujets là donc on a suivi quasi en
direct
l'annonce du fond dans la presse et on
s'est mis au travail immédiatement
vous dites on nous a dit on est
identifié
et donc il s'agit de secrétaire général
d'accord
c'est mieux de le préciser
ça évite toute interprétation
donc à ce moment-là
j'ai bien suivi le 12 13 vous entendez
vous viviez quasiment en direct
l'annonce du fond Marianne et à ce
moment là vous
présenter
un tout nouveau projet ou le projet qui
fait suite au premier à la première
réalisation j'imagine alors nous ce
qu'on a présenté c'est
une version plus aboutie
de ce qu'on faisait déjà voilà nous on
avait déjà travaillé sur la plateforme
de marque on avait déjà notre logo on
avait déjà notre identité visuelle on
avait déjà notre stratégie éditoriale
notre positionnement on avait déjà tout
ça et donc ce qu'on a fait c'était
vraiment de préciser pour entrer pour
pour répondre à un appel à projet il y a
quand même une liste de documents qu'il
faut fournir donc on les a on les a
fournis les uns après les autres on a
retravaillé de manière plus précise
notamment le chiffrage
et mais l'ADN de ce qu'on a présenté
existait déjà
oui donc j'allais dire c'est une montée
en puissance
peut-être
je vous livre une interprétation
possible peut-être que les contacts vous
aviez eu fin 2020 avec le préfet Gravel
qui validait ce que vous aviez ou qui
partagait vos objectifs
vous avez donc un premier soutien vous
et vous comprenez à travers les
échanges donc que vous avez avec lui que
en montant en puissance vous risquez
d'être tenu donc vous restez globalement
sur la ligne de votre premier projet
vous l'adapter évidemment mais il n'y a
pas besoin de faire
de virages à 180 degrés enfin voilà
finalement le la voix est tracé et vous
faites en sorte de cocher les cases de
l'appel à projet pour avoir un nouveau
soutien
avec donc
un accompagnement
donc finalement pour vous le fait
d'avoir
donc alors le 13 vous avez dit vous avez
un nouvel échange c'est 12 13 il se
trouve que le 13 il y a aussi un comité
de coordination qui se réunit avant
l'appel le dépôt du fond Marianne enfin
l'annonce vous n'êtes là pas mis
particulièrement dans la boucle en
disant préparez-vous il y a d'accord
à ce moment là vous n'avez aucune
information complémentaire et j'en
déduis que la durée finalement
relativement courte avec un week-end du
1er mai donc 20 avril 10 mai n'est pas
pour vous un obstacle majeur pour
présenter répondre à l'appel à projet
parce que finalement vous avez d'une
certaine manière un peu d'avance
naturelle puisque vous êtes vous un
premier projet qui a déjà je dirais
émerger le projet effectivement existait
déjà et et on s'est on a foncé en fait
on a foncé avec l'équipe pour pour
pouvoir délivrer un dossier dans les
temps qui puisse qu'ils puissent
convaincre et on a derrière nous une
expérience dans la réponse aux appels à
projets donc on a principalement
travaillé sur les questions de chiffrage
comme je vous l'ai dit et
voilà d'accord donc vos parcours
expérience professionnelle vous ont été
précieux
et le fait aussi que ce soit une
structure très petite et donc très agile
et donc les chaînes de décision sont
extrêmement rapides
ok est-ce que vous aviez connaissance
parce que vous arrivez dans un
[Musique]
comment dirais-je
un écosystème vous l'avez appelé comme
ça tout à l'heure et c'est vrai à la
fois un peu nouveau enfin moi ce qui
vous concerne j'ai compris que dans
l'association il y avait des nouveaux et
des gens plus engagés ou plus aguerris
au monde associatif voir politique
est-ce que vous avez connaissance ou
vous connaissez plutôt des associations
qui vont répondre aussi à cette non
on ne savait pas du tout nouveau vous
connaissez pas vous n'avez pas eu le
temps d'identifier
votre association moi ce que je note
c'est qu'elle est assez singulière
puisque vous l'avez dit il y a des
profils
avec des expériences professionnelles
plutôt diversifiée et avec des acteurs
en tous les cas au moins pour trois
d'entre eux puisque vous êtes ici
de la jeune génération on va dire comme
ça
moi j'enlève dans le dossier de
candidature pour l'essentiel vous n'avez
enfin je pense vous vous démontrez que
ce sont les les charges de rémunération
qui pèsent énormément puisque deux tiers
67% des charges portent sur le poste
rémunération
c'est à dire pour être précis 303000
euros sur
451000 euros
comment enfin quel comment vous
expliquer ces dépenses quel est le
finalement le choix les ou ceux qui vous
conduit à ce type
d'approche avec un poste de dépenses
dites charges de personnel élevées
alors nous on a été très clair des des
le dossier de candidature sur sur la
nature de notre projet et la nature de
notre projet repose beaucoup sur de la
création artistique et la création
artistique c'est c'est de la matière
grise c'est de l'humain et on avait dit
l'appel à projet je pense que c'était
marqué noir sur blanc que voilà on
n'avait pas salarié mais que on
prévoyait une vingtaine de
d'intervenants sur une quinzaine de
professions différentes soit par payer
soit par forfait mission soit par cacher
intermittent soit sur facture et
et si on regarde notre bilan à la fin de
l'action on était à 26 intervenants à
peu près donc on reste dans les pures
dans ce que de ce que nous avons prévu
et c'était c'est important je pense de
souligner deux choses la première c'est
c'est que
le projet en fait avait des phases très
différentes donc on avait besoin de
beaucoup de souplesse on avait besoin de
beaucoup de souplesse parce que sur les
premiers mois on était on était sur des
ressources autour de 90 personnes et on
est monté au pic vers mars avril où on
avait toutes les productions quasiment
en même temps on est monté à 26 et on a
aussi des des personnes qui sont
intervenues une semaine d'autres qui
sont intervenus six mois donc il fallait
gérer tout ça et rester dans les pures
de ce qu'on a dit et
je pense que sur ce point là nous avons
réussi
la question c'est on reste une structure
très jeune donc on est
on était sur notre premier grand
financement qui courait sur une durée
extrêmement limitée
on avait donc 330 000 euros à dépenser
avant juin 2022 même si nous dans notre
dans notre dans notre idée c'était un
projet pérenne moi en tant que
responsable
je ne pouvais pas salarié
dans ces conditions
des personnes
sans avoir on va dire une vision à long
terme des des rentrées d'argent
j'ai la même question que tout à l'heure
tout à l'heure on est parti d'un projet
de 70 000 réduit à 39000 la subvention
du cellulaire dans ce cas précis de tous
les plus lourds on est sur un projet
présenté à 451000 euros dont une partie
importante donc porté par le cpda est-ce
que là justement avec un peu plus de
temps etc est-ce que ce vous avez pu
franchir cet écueil de démarrage qui
était assez logique de pas trouver
d'argent dans les premiers surtout quand
on a encore un prouvé d'une façon mais
là vous aviez un peu un peu plus de
matière un peu plus est-ce que vous avez
pu compléter les choses ou est-ce qu'on
est resté toujours finalement sur un
projet présenté avec des subventions
autre mais finalement réduites à juste
ce qu'a donné des CI PDF je
ma réponse ressemble à ce que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure on est dans la même dans
les mêmes mécanismes c'est-à-dire dire
que on nous a demandé de présenter un
budget prévisionnel nous on a chiffré un
budget qui nous permettait de franchir
un cap voilà on s'est dit autour de 500
000 euros on peut franchir un cap dans
dans la façon avec laquelle on
appréhende nos productions et on avait
imaginé à l'époque rester dans un
dans un ratio 70 30% avec un 30% de
fonds privés et c'est comme je vous
disais tout à l'heure sur la question du
mécénat privé on a on a rencontré
beaucoup de gens
mais c'est un temps très court c'est à
dire que on a commencé vraiment à
publier sur les réseaux les premières
productions en janvier 2022
donc pour pouvoir entre janvier et juin
2022 tenir déjà sur le respect des
engagements qu'on avait et
des marchés aussi des mécènes privées on
n'avait pas on n'avait pas assez de
contenu de notre point de vue et aussi
il y avait pardon l'écueil lesquels que
je disais qui est que ce sont des sujets
extrêmement régaliens et qu'on avait des
difficultés à intéresser des fondations
sur ce sujet là donc juste pour finir
on est un budget prévisionnel mais on
l'a adapté en fait c'est à dire que
on avait tout le temps vous l'avez
adapté au montant que vous aviez été la
subvention on a négocié tous nos
contrats on a tout enfin on faisait des
points budgétaires très régulièrement
pour être sûr de notre atterrissage et
pour bien
c'est un sujet d'ailleurs qui est pas
comment sur ce fond mais de manière
générale je pense que l'État demande
toujours qui est une présentation de
budget avec une partie
de recherche de financement autre que
celui de l'État et d'ailleurs si vous
présentiez un financement à 100% état
d'une certaine façon il serait rejeté en
tant que tel bon donc si vous voulez la
question qu'on se pose toujours c'est la
question entre
votre subvention a été financière en
totalité on y reviendra tout à l'heure
mais ce qui veut dire que finalement
l'État à la fois demande qu'il ne
présentation avec une partie privée mais
si elle n'y est pas c'est pas une c'est
pas une raison pour comment dire réduire
leur subvention etc de fait de fait il y
a la demande et vous répondez à l'apocal
est déjà une certaine façon mais après
si c'est compliqué
on constate la bonne volonté
éventuellement d'avoir recherché des
partenaires mais ça va pas au-delà de ça
en réalité et on se retrouve très
souvent c'est pas vrai que dans ce cas
c'est vrai dans ce sens sportive
culturel enfin on peut trouver
1000 sujets où on a souvent ce décalage
entre la 2
l'idée que l'État avait un participer
mais pas la totalité et puis la réalité
qui est souvent les subventions
publiques qui font le projet voilà c'est
encore
le ce qui veut dire dans votre
fonctionnement contrairement à d'autres
associations vous l'avez dit vous n'êtes
pas choisi de salariés et je vais
revenir dans la question suivante
globalement on a bien vu dans les
éléments que vous nous avez transmis
beaucoup d'intervenants
finalement
réaliser leurs prestations sous le
statut d'auto-entrepreneur ce qui vous
permet d'avoir des rémunérations avec
honoraires et comme vous dites c'est
plus facile à ajuster parce que en
fonction des besoins la dépense n'est
pas la même alors ça pèse
plus lourde mais voilà c'est c'est juste
parce que comme on a eu une audition
avant vis-à-vis de nos collègues pour
resituer les choses j'ai noté juste
j'avais une dernière question sur le
sujet du fond Marianne mais vous avez
dit tout à l'heure quand je vous ai pris
la question sur ce point là nous avons
réussi
ce qui m'amène à vous poser une question
sur quel point parce que ça veut dire
certainement sur d'autres on n'a pas
réussi sur quel point et ce que vous
pouvez nous dire pour quelle raison ça
n'a pas vous n'avez pas atteint les
objectifs que vous fixiez autre alors
sur sur ce financement là
c'était évident qu'on finançait une
saison pilote et donc on était plus axé
recherche et développement on était
vraiment sur il faut constituer une
équipe il faut trouver des personnes qui
sont intéressées par le sujet des
personnes qui ont des compétences des on
a essayé aussi de d'équilibrer entre des
profils seniors et des profils plus
jeunes pour avoir voilà un budget
équilibré et
et pour nous ça c'était vraiment le
premier la première étape la première
étape pour nous c'était le recrutement
c'était le fait de poser les fondations
d'un récit et de pouvoir produire un
certain nombre de de format qui soit
autonomisable et
et différent et qui traitent maximum de
facettes on va dire de notre projet donc
nous nos objectifs en fait sur sur
cette convention là on était vraiment
sur quelque chose de qualitatif on était
sur quelque chose de qualitatif et sur
des objectifs on va dire de
pouvoir à la fin de cette saison pilote
stabiliser la plateforme commun en ayant
testé un certain nombre enfin voilà il y
a des formats qui ont qui ont marché à
des formats qui ont un peu moins bien
marché il y a des formats on a repéré
des des évolutions possibles et tout ce
travail là il était absolument
nécessaire de le mener à un moment donné
puisque on n'avait pas
encore une fois de
en faisant notre benchmark en fait on
n'avait pas de repère c'était ce qu'on
faisait était assez nouveau et donc il
fallait passer par cette par cette par
cette phase là et voilà
d'accord dernière question
un membre du cpdr s'est étonné
on a retrouvé des communications par
mail de justement de ce que votre
association
n'avait pas de personnel
embauchés notamment puisque vous l'avez
dit création d'une association nouvelle
un budget qui est pour une création pas
tout à fait neutre près de 500 000 euros
et notamment quand il faut gérer vous
avez dit jusqu'à 24
intervenants
la question c'est souvent on se dit mais
qui comment est assuré la gestion
financière donc comment est-ce que vous
avez procédé comment même éventuellement
avez-vous justifié le fait de ne
recourir à aucun emploi salarié même à
temps partiel ou une mission pour
assurer la au regard de la demande du
CEP Dr la bonne les scènes gestion de
l'association
alors comme je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure nous on a des le dossier de
candidature et dans la convention on a
on a bien montré que on l'association
reposer sur un travail bénévole et
reposer sur un certain nombre de
prestations intellectuelles
qui sont rémunérés soit par forfait
mission soit par cachet d'intermittent
nous personnellement j'ai c'est un
montant qui ne m'a pas inquiété parce
que
on a l'habitude en tout cas dans dans
chez les dirigeants de l'association de
de gérer des projets beaucoup plus
complexes avec des montants beaucoup
plus importants et des enjeux beaucoup
plus forts donc il y avait quand même un
savoir-faire même si l'objet change le
savoir-faire de du pilotage d'un projet
sur le temps en termes de temps et en
termes de budget il y a des choses qui
ne varient pas et donc il y avait cette
expérience là de comment mettre en place
une feuille de route comment adapter un
budget comment gérer le relationnel avec
avec nos partenaires et tout ça c'était
un autre niveau et vu notre expérience
ça se passait plutôt bien
et on avait en termes opérationnel on
avait une directrice de projet qui était
une consultante externe et pareil
sont sa rémunération était adaptée en
fonction des phases et cette personne
a aussi beaucoup d'expérience
elle avait déjà monté sa propre
entreprise elle avait déjà une
expérience solide dans le pilotage de
projet et donc en fait on a rapidement
mis en place un certain nombre de
process et un certain nombre de méthodes
qui ont fait que
que tous ces déroulés sereinement en
tout cas
merci
merci beaucoup alors quelques questions
peut-être dans la salle Vincent et blé
d'abord
merci monsieur le Président Madame
Menouni je voulais vous interroger sur
les débuts de votre association je n'ai
pas tout à fait très bien compris tout à
l'heure
si je crois que c'est le cas votre
association a été créée peu de temps
avant l'appel à projet et qu'en fait
vous avez pu percevoir ces sommes du
fond Marianne dans votre première année
d'existence en ce qui me concerne j'ai
présidé pendant 11 ans une grande
collectivité française pendant les 11
années jamais la collectivité n'a
accordé il n'y a pas d'interdiction
légale mais jamais un accordé ne
serait-ce que 250 euros de subvention un
club de retraité ou un club de gym si
l'association n'était pas en capacité de
présenter un bilan financier d'une
première année de fonctionnement donc
pas de subvention publique dans la
première année de fonctionnement pour
des raisons qu'on peut comprendre est-ce
que ces raisons d'une certaine façon
vous les comprenez est-ce que cette
exigence non pas légale je ça peut être
mais de déontologie en quelque sorte qui
renvoie à celui qui distribue l'argent
mais qui peut aussi interroger celui qui
perçoit les sommes est-ce que c'est une
question que personnellement vous vous
êtes posé en tant que président de
l'association est-ce que autour de vous
des dirigeants ont évoqué cette question
avec vous est-ce que votre conseil
administration votre bureau a eu en
connaître et est-ce que vous vous êtes
posé la question de savoir si ça n'était
pas trop vite trop tôt
et voilà quel élément vous avez à nous
dire sur cette élément qui on l'a vu
dans la presse dans des commentaires
dont j'ai compris que en grande partie
il vous en choqué est-ce que cette
question j'irai vous comprenez qu'elle
puisse poser un questionnement ou ou pas
du tout ou est-ce que vous assumez
complètement alors moi je on est
toujours parti du principe que les choix
de l'administration étaient motivés donc
nous on dépose des demandes de
subvention et on considère que si elles
sont acceptées c'est qu'on a respecté
toutes les règles voilà je
pour moi c'est une question qui faut
poser à
l'administration nous on a juste foncé
on a juste foncé parce que on a senti on
a senti un alignement sur sur le projet
on a on avait envie je sais avait envie
et on ne sait pas poser 12000 questions
très sincèrement voilà on part du
[Musique]
non je ne regrette rien
oui
bien
merci
Vincent il y a pas d'autres questions
nos collègues je n'en vois pas je vous
propose de poursuivre alors on va après
ces éléments qui étaient
très important sur le le mode de
fonctionnement qui est effectivement
quand même par rapport à d'autres choses
qu'on a pu voir très différents d'abord
les
comment dire à ceux qui créent
l'association de ce sont pas salarié sur
le projet première élément
important deuxièmement finalement vous
avez une gestion en fonction des
montants que vous avez la réalité le
seul sujet qui nous pose un peu problème
c'est que j'ai indiqué tout à l'heure
mais bon
sont prêts à vous croire sur l'idée que
vous avez des recherches de financement
dans un domaine
vous l'avez dit qu'il sans doute si
prête à ces peu facilement quoi de dire
ça en dehors de tomber sur quelque chose
d'entreprise extrêmement
intéressé par le sujet de la laïcité ça
peut arriver il y en a mais bon il faut
les trouver bon voilà donc en dehors de
ça c'est une des problématiques que l'on
a donc mais sur des sommes quand même
très importantes parce que vous dites
c'est pas descendre important de vous le
dites en tant que professionnel si je
viens je suis prêt à le partager mais en
termes associatif ce sont des ce sont
des montants très importants pour une
association
qui n'est pas créée pour cela mais qui
vient d'être créé bon voilà et donc
c'est un point c'est un point
significatif que de voir que finalement
seul la subvention publique permet
finalement d'assurer cette première
année sans aide complémentaire même si
elles ont été recherchés on en a bien
pris note
alors on va on va venir maintenant sur
les problèmes de contenu et encore une
fois dont vous avez montré des contenus
on va on va évidemment montrer un peu
les contenus que vous allez évoquer
vous-même dans la dernière juste pour
les présenter et encore une fois
nous n'irons absolument pas nous
interdirons d'aller sur la question de
savoir si c'est de nature comment dire a
déclencher quelle action
judiciaire que ce soit c'est pas notre
sujet d'aujourd'hui on va aller sur
d'autres d'autres éléments mais d'abord
regardons quelques quelques éléments de
production qui ont posé problème qui
sont sur la place publique maintenant on
va les revoir rapidement
alors c'est la série vous le savez à la
bonne franquette
et le truc c'est quoi et même les
vieux de rien parce qu'ils ont pas pu
enfin être visité de manière
eux tu vois
mourir mais en plus dans des manières
totalement indécentes je ne sais pas en
fait tout le monde
est tout le monde est sacrifié en fait
la seule personne qui n'a pas été
sacrifiée c'était Macron et
tu as raison moi je suis d'accord
non mais je veux dire en fait justement
comme ce que je disais tout à l'heure il
disait faire faire passer l'humain avant
l'économie etc mais c'est faux c'est
faux en fait ça a toujours été faux
sur Paris pour faire la bringue pour
s'éclater en mode tu sais j'ai une
chemise blanche blazer et tout il est là
pour tout déchirer un soir il tombe il
va vous mettre union la boîte enfin
boîte barre escort tout ça un peu classe
il tombe sur Castaner qui est un autre
illustre fêtard qui lui dit
si le Président je le connais très bien
figure-toi que c'est grave un pote c'est
mon meilleur pote et la PAF Miss de la
santé comme ça d'un coup tu vois toi ton
entretien d'embauche à toi c'est où
est-ce que vous voyez dans 5 ans et tout
lui non c'est juste un verre au maximum
ça se passe comme ça c'est bien c'est la
macronie on aime beaucoup ouais ça tient
une carrière à quoi ça tient une
carrière c'est pour ça que je ne veux
pas taper sur lui le mec est arrivé dans
la politique par hasard tu vois c'est au
détour d'une boîte de nuit c'est pas
comme ça c'est une victime du macronisme
un peu comme chacun de nous comme toi
comme moi comme moi comme toi comme tout
le monde
et si on doit aussi on devait faire le
procès à quelqu'un je crois que beaucoup
d'autres le doubleraient dans le
calendrier judiciaire je pense surtout à
Sibeth and Day quel prénom incroyable si
bête elle a pas un prénom exceptionnel
c'est-à-dire que les parents ils ont
tout de suite senti venir le truc sont
des sans déconner c'est le prénom le
mieux porté de France avec Anne Hidalgo
j'aime beaucoup
bon si alors moi j'aime pas Mélenchon
parce que non je sais je sais encore
le droit
en 2032 je vais revenir avec le pantalon
il a eu quelques il a eu quelques
remarques et quelques réflexions qui
m'ont un peu qui m'ont un peu dégoûté du
personnage mais c'est pas vraiment ça
mais c'est pas vraiment lui qui me fait
peur entre guillemets c'est les gens qui
noyau autour de lui c'est les c'est les
décolonialistes c'est les ouais c'est ça
c'est le parti des Indigènes de la
République c'est toute cette expérience
là un peu qui est vraiment pour le coup
extrémiste et qui est très dangereuse et
nous on est content de enfin de ils sont
distinctes pas en fait
je serai plus à même de parler de Paris
vu que c'est la seule ville dans
laquelle j'ai vécu vraiment et que je
connais plus ou moins je sais que on
paye énormément taxe d'habitation et
c'est d'ailleurs j'ai et la plupart des
riverains des citoyens Parisiens ont
l'impression qu'en fait c'est pour
financer le grand train des de la de
toute la toute la cohorte qui suit la
mère la mère et c'est tous ses adjoints
je crois qu'elle a 27 adjoints je crois
qu'il y a personne en France et
peut-être personne en Europe aucun édile
aucun bourgmestre en Belgique qui a
bourgmestres
ils vivent dans un week-end c'est
vraiment des psychopathes mais bon ok il
y a aucun rapport il y a aucun chef de
chef de village qui a autant de
clientèle areopage de de de de d'adjoint
autour de lui et
caprice de ma part et le truc
alors on a vous avez vu qu'on a
équilibré les choses avec
des hommes aux femmes politiques de
droite ou macronistes et de gauche de
manière à présenter une palette une
palette large bon de ces éléments alors
encore une fois
l'élément fadit-il
au regard de la loi je veux dire enfin
est-il le faire ou pas ça ne PNF dire à
ce qu'il a à dire
sur le sujet par rapport à des plaines
qui ont été déposées
qui nous concerne pas à ce stade donc on
revient sur finalement le rôle de alors
je t'ai indiqué que si vous souhaitiez
intervenir à la demande de la présidente
bien sûr vous devriez le faire en
prétancièrement d'abord juste dans les
formes quoi voilà c'est tout ce que je
veux vous dire mais je vous incite pas
non plus c'est la présidente qui
décidera mais je clarifie ce point donc
on va venir sur ça et sur les
discussions et finalement ce qui nous
intéresse c'est la relation entre vous
et le cipdr dès l'instant où ces
messages apparaissent et à quel moment
finalement le cpdr ça ne me auprès de
vous et vous demande une correction
alors on sait qu'elle a eu lieu parce
que quelque part dans un des messages on
dit la présidente
a été informé qu'elle ne pouvons nous
pouvions pas etc donc il y a eu
effectivement cet échange sans vous
allez nous le dire et on va y venir mais
tout d'abord moi quand j'ai j'ai passé
un peu de temps à regarder à regarder
ces vidéos alors il y a dans l'ensemble
des vidéos je les dis tout à l'heure en
introduction il y a des choses qui qui
m'ont sur le fond le contenu j'ai pas
m'exprimer dessus puis d'ailleurs je
n'ai aucune position d'expert sur ce
qu'il faut faire passer comme message
sur laïcité mais en tout cas sur la
forme donc c'était bien filmé bien
enregistrer enfin c'est pas c'était pas
bricolé ça c'est assez clair sur
la question qui pose donc sur le fond de
ces interventions et est-ce qu'elles
étaient je parle des autres formats
est-ce qu'ils étaient en lien d'être
compris par le public visé
on peut toujours s'interroger vous avez
montré d'ailleurs quelques quelques
enregistrements avec quelqu'un qui parle
je crois en visio
qui a une expression
philosophiquement forte mais je suis pas
sûr que un public jeune rentre très
facilement dans ses concepts tels qu'ils
ont été présentés mais bon voilà j'ai
pas tout moi-même je veux dire que j'ai
revu des fois plusieurs reprises pour
essayer de bien voir le sens de ce qui
était dit c'est pour dire que c'était
mon point de vue c'est un petit peu
complexe quelquefois d'y rentrer pas
toujours mais bon mais c'est les
contenus et à la limite c'est aussi PDR
de dire ce qu'elle a à dire la qualité
des sujets encore une fois je n'en ai
pas la compétence et mon avis ne compte
pas par contre sur ce qu'on vient de
voir c'est à dire quelque chose donc un
format
tout à fait particulier de conversation
un petit peu sous la forme de café du
commerce
m'excusant de cette formule mais bon
en échange librement voilà sans trop de
préparation sur le sur le fond moi la
question que je me pose c'est par
rapport je les remets en perspective
avec les deux éléments qu'on a dit qu'on
a donné au départ c'est-à-dire essayer
d'avoir un discours positif alors vous
avez nuancé vous avez des positifs mais
engagés enfin je veux dire pas positif
au point que
c'est plus trop voilà non avec des
choses assez claires qui sont dites on
l'entend et un discours apaisé
alors quand on regarde ça malgré tout on
a du mal à voir le discours apaisé
quand on met en cause les personnes
après les autres bon et quand avoir le
discours républicain on peut quand même
se dire ou se demander si quand même
quand on défend les valeurs de la
République on ne doit pas dans les
valeurs de la République éviter autant
que faire se peut éviter
de s'attaquer à leur représentant bon
voilà alors je
sens que j'aurais pas une appréciation
positive de votre part sur ce point mais
mais cela étant dit je vous le pose
comme ça parce que quand on s'adresse à
des gens qui sont loin
quand on veut s'adresser à des gens qui
sont loin de la République et on
commence à dire tous les tous les élus
bon ils sont pas des pourris c'est pas
dit comme ça mais enfin on va les
dénigrer etc je suis pas sûr que ça ait
bien dans le sens voilà et j'ai lu
d'ailleurs vous avez un moment donné
fait passer une information en disant je
suis assez fier de contenu de manière
global et
vous avez dit tout là encore je ne
regrette rien des contenus qui sont
faits mais quand même nous sans vouloir
être vous voyez des défenseurs à tout
prix nos fonctions etc le sujet mais
dans le message qui est envoyé sur des
fonds publics je remets en relation sur
des fonds publics qui sont liés à
construire un discours positif sur la
République on a du mal à suivre
alors je vais essayer de répondre à
votre question un peu à tiroir donc si
je si je passe un point n'hésitez pas à
me le rappeler
la première chose
qu'il faut savoir en tout cas pour nous
c'est
que nous n'avons nous nous sommes pas
des prestataires du cipdr on a été
on a été
sélectionné sur un projet et ce projet
avait une ligne éditoriale qui dès la
candidature comme je disais en trois
points productif
avait pour objet entre autres de de
réagir à l'actualité et de faire du
divertissement politique généraliste
parler de politique en France
c'est la politique est hyper
personnalisée il y a des figures on ne
peut pas parler d'un certain nombre de
sujets sans mentionner ses figures donc
ça fait partie on nous on a essayé en
tout cas bien avant les les échanges
avec le cipdr parce que d'ailleurs la la
l'extrait dans ton parle et dans lequel
visiblement des consignes sont passées
c'est un épisode qui a été tourné le 8
janvier et qui en fait est issu de notre
premier débrief sur le premier épisode
qui a été tourné et sur le premier
épisode qui a été tourné et les équipes
on a parlé nous on croyait vraiment à se
format on va dire informel apéro filmé
un peu détente etc que il fallait
trouver il fallait épouser les codes de
ce qui marche sur les réseaux sociaux
parce que les codes qui marchent aussi
le clash la personnalisation etc et
c'était difficile pour nous
de
trouver on va dire le bon ton entre ce
qui permet la viralité sur les réseaux
sociaux et ce qu'on défend c'est à dire
un débat apaisé alors un débat apaisé
c'est pas forcément un débat
lisse et si on regarde les extraits
alors c'est vrai que
s'ils sont ils sont extraits de leur
contexte ça peut paraître un peu
un peu difficile à entendre mais la
réalité c'est que si on prend toutes les
séquences parce que là on est en train
de parler de
quelques minutes sur 22 heures de
programmes quelques minutes sur 22h de
programmes et sur 16 heures de
programmes en tout cas pour à la bonne
franquette si on on voit les sujets qui
sont traités et la façon avec laquelle
ils ont été traités il y a toujours eu
autour de la table des avis différents
il y a toujours tout le monde c'est
écouter il y a eu des blagues acides oui
il y a eu des analyses politiques oui
on n'a aucun problème avec ça et
le message que on avait passé début
janvier et qu'on a tenu pendant toute la
période de production c'est OK voilà
c'est un apéro filmé on est un peu dans
une ambiance grande gueule mais il faut
tout de même élever le débat et il faut
tout de même limiter la personnalisation
de
des débats et ça c'était
c'était déjà dans les tuyaux bien avant
le premier point d'étape avec avec le
cipdr
je ne sais pas du coup si j'ai répondu à
toute la question
à défaut d'y avoir répondu moi je peux
pas m'empêcher de de faire le lien avec
l'appel à projet du fond Marianne autour
de la question religion et laïcité
j'ai du mal donc je vous pose la
question à voir en quoi un certain
nombre de vos
émissions et publications
concours à reconstruire le commun
parfois vous vous opposez les artistes
belges et les artistes français alors
sous le don de voilà du deuxième degré
quand vous parlez d'écologie vous avez
tendance
opposé
les boomers et la jeune génération quand
vous regardez la crise sanitaire c'est
aussi sous l'angle de la jeunesse
sacrifiée
et je redis enfin voilà vous êtes
présidente de reconstruire le commun
donc on est de la déchiffre là mais
puisque c'est évoqué par une question du
Président et par le
votre intervention j'avoue que
je titre personnel en tout cas je n'y
trouve pas vraiment mon compte et
notamment le compte de l'objectif qui
est de répondre à l'appel à projet de
[Musique]
valeur avant de reconstruire le commun
il faut écouter la parole des jeunes
est-ce que vous avez entendu non à la
bonne franquette même si c'était parfois
un peu cash c'est ce que pensent les
jeunes les jeunes s'opposent au boomer
sur les questions d'écologie les jeunes
ont vraiment vécu la crise sanitaire
comme un sacrifice c'est ce qu'il pense
c'est ce qu'ils ont dit et moi je ne les
ai pas censurés il n'y a pas de raison
de les censurer puisque
c'est une analyse politique comme une
autre et moi je
veux dire que je comprends votre
surprise mais
pour moi
la première étape c'est d'entendre c'est
d'entendre ce que ces gens ont à dire et
d'essayer à partir de là de construire
quelque chose donc une parole peut
choquer y compris dans d'autres formats
du type du quiz il y a eu des paroles
voilà qui sont
qui sont libres mais qui ont toujours
respecté la loi
voilà enfin bon moi je pense que comment
dirais-je
puisque vous parlez de reconstruire le
commun j'entends dans la démarche
associative et de ce que vous avez
exprimé jusqu'à maintenant enfin
j'entends qu'il y a la volonté de de
donner une place à l'expression
je rappelle autour au départ des
religions la laïcité de ce qui enferme
de ce qui ouvre et vous le dites bien de
reconstruire s'il y a reconstruire on
peut entendre des réflexions moi je les
entends comme vous de toute façon quand
je les entends pas elle s'exprime y
compris dans les bulletins de vote donc
je vais pas au-delà mais donc simplement
cette réponse à l'appel à projet et les
contenus voilà que je les ai découverts
par le travail que nous menons voilà
chacun va chercher je dirais sont enfin
ces informations notamment sur les
réseaux sociaux comme ça se multiplie
voilà il y a plus ou moins de filtres et
c'est la responsabilité de l'association
j'ai pas de j'ai pas de souci majeur
mais juste après la projet et dans les
éléments
qu'on voit enfin je trouve
un décalage relatif
vous noterez que c'est pas d'ailleurs
l'ensemble du travail de l'association
nous parlons il y a plusieurs formats
nous parlons d'un format particulier qui
pose des questions particulières et qui
nous inquiète alors on
se convaincra pas je puis dire donc
c'est pas la peine d'y revenir 30 fois
les uns et les autres mais
revenons par contre à la relation avec
le cipdr sur cette question là justement
donc
finalement il y a eu des il y a eu c'est
logique c'est une vous êtes une nouvelle
association
[Musique]
j'osais dire que le secrétaire général
en proposant une subvention importante à
votre association mais en vous une
confiance ça c'est un discutable dans
votre dans ce projet en tout cas vous
avez dit tout à l'heure qu'il était
d'ailleurs qui avait été extrêmement
positif lorsqu'ils vous avez reçu la
première fois
le sujet il y a pas de il y a pas de
doute et derrière donc il y a des il y a
un certain nombre de relations sur les
contenus justement qui sont produits
c'est-à-dire sur le suivi de l'opération
sur le suivi financier bon il y a pas
les choses se font
semblent-ils convenablement enfin en
tout cas dans l'état de de nos éléments
d'appréciation mais donc ça ne porte pas
a priori sur ce sur ces angles là en
tout cas on met pas l'accent sur ça mais
sur les contenus et justement quelques
contenus un peu difficiles donc vous
avez des contacts ici PDR c'est PDR il
vous parle ces contenus
délicats en quel terme et à ce que
est-ce qu'à ce moment-là on revient sur
cette question de faites attention sur
il y a des sujets politiques sur
lesquels enfin qui mériterait d'être
traité différemment est-ce que est-ce
que c'est conversations ont lieu ou non
alors je l'ai déjà dit mais je le
rappelle nous on n'était pas des
prestataires du cipdr et dans ce
cadre-là
sous contrôle du cipdr et au final et au
final c'est même le seul financement de
ces opérations donc alors vous pouvez
toujours dire on n'est pas des
sous-traitants
intellectuellement ça il y a aucun souci
mais il y a bien une relation entre du
financement public et bon et il y a bien
un débat sur les contenus ça c'est c'est
sûr voilà et après c'est à vous de dire
mais je continue je continue pas je
modifie voilà c'est ça qu'on voudrait
alors
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que je voulais dire
je vais reprendre le fil
tous ces tous ces sujets en fait pour
nous
relève plutôt de l'appréciatif c'est à
dire que nous on présentait un certain
nombre de de
format on les présentait avant même et
le fait qu'on nous dise on aime on
n'aime pas ok on l'entendait mais
c'était pas c'était pas pour nous
[Musique]
pour nous c'était hors champ du du
contrat qui nous liait donc on
l'entendait parce que bien sûr il faut
préserver une relation avec avec notre
partenaire surtout si on avait dans
l'idée de poursuivre
donc voilà mais mais foncièrement nous
on a toujours tenu à notre liberté
éditoriale dans le respect dans le
respect de la loi évidemment et le cipdr
nous a à l'occasion
d'un ou deux points
signifier que il y avait une blague anti
Macron qui qui les a pas franchement
fait rire et qui on a eu un échange tout
à fait normal
et bienvenu sur le fait que
on est dans une période sensible qui est
la période électorale et que donc si on
doit traiter de sujets politiques voilà
il faut faire un peu attention mais ça
on l'avait déjà intégré pour nous
c'était évident mais
on ne pouvait pas ne pas parler de
sujets politiques on ne pouvait pas le
faire dans une émission d'un
fauteuilment qui se lance dans cette
période enfin particulière toute
l'attention médiatique tout tout le
traitement médiatique de la question
politique entre janvier et juin été
tourné autour des enjeux de la
présidentielle donc on s'était dit que
c'était important de les traiter et de
de
de laisser les chroniqueurs s'exprimer
néanmoins je tiens à le rappeler et par
rapport à la période stricte de la
campagne on a publié aucun compte aucun
contenu à caractère politique et
c'est remarques du cipdr donc qui ont
été faites une ou deux fois n'ont jamais
été
véritablement un point à l'ordre du jour
de nos réunions
qui n'ont jamais fait l'objet d'un
courrier
mais je peux vous assurer monsieur le
Président c'est que si j'avais un début
de phrase dans un mail qui parlait de ça
mais on aurait réagi immédiatement alors
je ne dis pas comment on aurait réagi on
aurait pris un arbitrage en interne en
disant Stop ou Encore stop on veut
garder notre ADN tant pis pour les
financements ou non non on veut tenir ce
financement et voilà il faut il faut
faire des compromis on aurait pris un
arbitrage mais on l'aurait pris
immédiatement et on l'aurait signifié
immédiatement et et on avait je peux le
dire aussi on n'avait pas on n'avait pas
peur d'aller au contentieux parce que on
remplissait toutes les obligations de de
notre contrat
bien donc vous nous bon vous nous dites
quand en gros s'il y a eu quelques
remarques elles ont été orales elles
étaient pas dans les n'étaient pas dans
un ordre du jour au moment ni dans aucun
compte-rendu écrit voilà donc
il y avait une appréciation qui a été
faite à partir surtout de de
d'un peu d'humour manifester sur le
président de la République qui a donné
lieu à une remarque un peu acide et pas
et rien au-delà de ça
comment votre plateforme comme un était
l'organisé qui comment était défini les
formats qui étaient responsables des
choix les validations comment voilà
comment
ce dispositif est-il organisé et si
j'ose le dire maîtriser alors on a un
petit document que vous transmettrai
à la fin de cette de cette séance où on
détaille vraiment face par phase et
format PERFORMA les process qui ont été
mis en place et et comment alors comment
on concevait et on produisait mais aussi
ce qui était important c'est à quel
moment l'équipe opérationnelle
demander une validation à la aux
dirigeants de l'association donc sur les
contenus sur les sur les sujets abordés
moi ce que je peux vous dire alors vous
le verrez en détail je vous transmettrai
le document mais en gros sur un format
quel qu'il soit la première étape
c'était déjà de décider qu'on allait le
lancer bien sûr et de de définir un
cadre et de recruter les les bonnes
ressources à partir de là il y avait
souvent une réunion de lancement à
laquelle on assistait
pour présenter un peu l'ADN de
l'association pour que voilà les les
intervenants
s'imprègnent de notre état d'esprit et
ensuite c'était la chef de projet qui
dirigeait qui dirigeait la conception et
la production et nous on valider les
sujets donc on intervenait au moment de
une fois que un sujet une proposition de
sujet choisie on l'a validé et on
valider les scripts et on validait
toutes les vidéos avant publication donc
on intervenait un certain nombre de de
d'étapes et c'était assez cadré
d'accord dans le
dans les dans les contenus toujours il y
a une note du secrétaire général donc de
juin 2022 qui
donc
attire l'attention
de manière solennelle sur des contenus
qui ne conviennent pas et notamment par
rapport au discours séparatiste et à la
promotion des valeurs républicaines
finalement je reviens un peu au sujet
que j'ai déjà évoqué tout à l'heure
et d'ailleurs dans la note du 2 juin il
est indiqué que le préfet a été très
ferme sur les fameux contenus politiques
comment
expliquer vous que
le phénomène est je dirais perdurer
alors
moi je vais revenir sur cette réunion du
2 juin j'ai lu dans la presse et j'ai
entendu Noël audition que on a été
convoqué moi je n'ai jamais été
convoquée j'ai assisté à des réunions de
suivi et j'ai assisté à des points
d'étape et d'ailleurs cette réunion
c'était à mon initiative après relance
pour obtenir un rendez-vous pour
présenter un prêt bilan
avant la fin de la convention ça me
paraissait normal de de rencontrer le
cipda de manière plus formelle avec une
présentation plus aboutie avant de
d'arriver à la fin donc cette réunion a
été à mon initiative
l'ordre du jour c'était le point d'étape
le une forme de pré bilan et
on a été principalement
renvoyé
à nos résultats
c'était le cœur du sujet vraiment
c'était
que pour eux les résultats n'étaient pas
au niveau attendu alors après on peut
débattre de quel était le niveau attendu
mais mais le fond de la discussion
c'était ça et puis après il y a eu des
échanges sur le la qualité la qualité du
du projet
et nous
une fois que le secrétaire général donc
a dit tout ce qu'il avait à dire
il est parti et il nous a pas laissé
l'occasion de répondre donc est-ce que
vous avez
senti ou est-ce que vous avez été averti
qui avait un risque de ne pas percevoir
le solde de la subvention de 25 % et
comment se versement se sol de comment
s'est-il passé alors à aucun moment
nous
on a déposé notre demande de versement
de sol le 11 mai le 11 mai est à cette
occasion j'avais redemandé d'avoir un
rendez-vous à horizon fermé début juin
et suite à cette réunion
donc moi j'ai relancé pour avoir mon
pouvoir où ça en était
et tous les échanges que j'ai eu avec le
cipdr jusqu'au versement qui a eu lieu
le 8 juillet
tous les échanges que j'ai eu portés sur
un sur ce qui était strictement
administratif c'est à dire les documents
que je remplis si tout était carré etc
et moi ce qu'on m'avait dit c'était que
c'était la fin d'année donc il y avait
forcément beaucoup de conventions qui
arrivaient à terme donc il y avait un
bouchon et qu'il fallait pas s'inquiéter
et alors j'ai été un peu insistante
parce que
voilà j'avais j'avais des prestataires
dont certains quand on est des petites
entreprises on n'a pas forcément
beaucoup de trésorerie donc
j'ai fait en sorte de suivre très
précisément ce dossier
mais c'est vrai que
entre le 11 mai et le 8 juillet alors
déjà c'est une durée qui est pas
qui est assez correcte pour une
administration on n'est pas dans deux
mois entre une demande et un virement on
est sur quelque chose de relativement
classique
et il n'y a eu aucun
aucun échange dans le cadre de ce
versement qui porte sur autre chose que
le
que sur le côté financier
très bien donc
une dernière question entre cette
période là de fin de projet de fond
Marianne et le mois de mars 2023 et
la sortie dans la presse c'est un nombre
de
sujets dont vous avez fait partie
il y a-t-il eu des échanges entre vous
et aussi PDR PDR ou pas du tout ce que
après cette réunion du 2 juin et la
façon avec laquelle c'était déroulée
nous on s'est posé beaucoup de questions
sur sur la sur la suite ce que
ce n'est pas une attitude qu'on
attendait dans le cas d'un partenariat
donc ça ça nous avait beaucoup travaillé
pendant l'été et ça avait remis en cause
on va dire nos projections à moyen terme
et
donc à la rentrée nous on a envoyé les
documents pour clôturer la
la subvention en octobre le bilan
détaillé en novembre le compte-rendu de
subvention
et
nous on a décidé de mettre en pause le
projet on a décidé de mettre en pause le
projet pour plusieurs raisons la
première c'est ce que je viens de dire
c'est que voilà vu comment vu le
partenariat avancé que on s'est rendu
compte en fait que le cipdr était sur
une approche plutôt quantitative plutôt
court thermiste sur un sur des formats
et des propos le plus consensuel
possible et nous on était sur quelque
chose de différent c'est à dire on était
plutôt sur du qualitatif on était sur du
long terme et et on était on abordait
les sujets qui fâchent donc en termes de
consensualité
voilà il y a des limites et donc à
partir de là il y a ce point là il y a
des points plus personnels en fait ou il
y a un membre de notre bureau qui a eu
des problèmes de santé très importants
donc donc
c'est on
s'était dit voilà il faut ça reste du
bénévolat il faut déjà se remettre sur
pied
au niveau de la santé et
attendre que ça s'éclaircisse pour
pouvoir rebondir donc il y avait ce
sujet là et puis on en a parlé à
plusieurs reprises pendant cette
audition c'est la difficulté aussi
d'avoir d'autres sources de financement
donc la décision a été prise
chez nous allaiter de mettre en pause
on s'était dit on reverra au printemps
quand ça ira mieux et puis le printemps
est arrivé avec ce que vous savez et
et voilà et on en est là et on en est là
exactement
enfin dernière question de l'audition
sauf s'il y a des questions de nos
collègues bien sûr dans la salle
vous l'avez d'ailleurs je crois évoquer
un moment donné dans votre peau
liminaire
on a maintenant une procédure de
remboursement qui a été initié
semble-t-il la semaine du 8 mai
donc avez-vous bien reçu
courrier là-dessus ou une information
et s'il y a eu une information avez-vous
répondu au secrétariat général déjà et
quelle est la teneur de cette réponse
je l'ai souligné en propoint introductif
parce que c'était vraiment important
pour nous
c'est demande de remboursement vraiment
on l'a pris en direct
on l'a appris en direct lors des
auditions et
en rentrant chez moi donc le 16 au soir
je retrouve dans ma boîte aux lettres
donc le recommander avec cette demande
de remboursement et
un contrôle à posteriori qui date alors
le courrier est signé de 12 mai vendredi
12 mai pour une audition le 16 mai
sachant que nous on a tout envoyé le 17
novembre 2022 on était
on avait tout envoyé donc entre le 17
novembre et le 12 mai on n'a pas eu de
contact avec
l'administration
avec le pôle financier qui aurait pu
peut-être nous demander des pièces
justificatives supplémentaires etc rien
du tout
et donc oui on a on a répondu on a
répondu à ce courrier et dans les temps
et nous on considère que le timing de ce
contrôle a posteriori
comment le dire poliment
restez poli
hypocrite je dirais et
en parallèle on a des échanges avec
enfin et voilà il y a trois enquêtes en
cours il y a la vôtre la commission
d'enquête avec vous il y a il y a l'IGA
qui fait son contrôle et qui nous a
demandé
toute une série de pièces on a tout
transmis ils ont tout et éventuellement
une information je disais on considère
que avec toutes ces enquêtes qui sont en
cours
le cipdr est des saisies de fait de ce
contrôle à posteriori puisque il est
déjà en cours par des autorités
indépendantes dont la vôtre
voilà
vous considérez que cette demande de
remboursement est passée en lien avec
les événements récents
pardon
oui considérer que cette demande de
remboursement n'est pas sans lien avec
des événements récents
mais vous entendez faire droit à la
demande de remboursement ou
si j'interprète bien votre propos c'est
pour l'instant stand by puisque il y a
des démarches
et pour vous si j'interprète vos propos
j'espère bien il y avait pas de raison
de faire ce type de réclamation puisque
depuis novembre 2022 vous avez bouclé le
dossier les comptes les éléments les
justificatifs tout à fait
très bien goûter on est presque arrivé
si vous souhaitez rajouter un mot
dites-moi
nous avons une question ça vous laisse
ça vous laissera peut-être le temps
une petite question qui avait déjà été
posée sur l'audition précédente est-ce
que des membres de l'association touché
des rémunérations un bulletin de salaire
ou des factures d'auto-entrepreneurs
est-ce que les membres de l'association
ont perçu quelques pas forcément les
dirigeants mais dans le bureau
l'association est-ce qu'il y a des gens
qui ont conçu des rémunérations
Marc la Mini
oui merci monsieur le Président merci
madame la Présidente très rapidement je
veux bien écouter comme l'ensemble des
collègues
alors la demande de remboursement dont
vous parlez c'est la totalité de la
subvention
font au mariage
voilà c'était c'était surtout cette
question et puis sur la petite
projection qu'on a vu
présente un département qui est
très proche de la Belgique alors là on
parlait des bourgmestres et des adjoints
alors je dirais à quel public c'était
parce que moi je suis pas du tout ni
mail ni réseau sociaux donc je suis un
peu à l'aise pour pour en parler je
reste encore au papier ou écrit
c'est encore les fondamentaux donc
justement à quel public c'était destiné
voilà merci beaucoup c'était
aux jeunes marques donc c'était pas nous
ça c'est ça c'est en tout cas très clair
le président alors
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président simplement
sur le je voudrais savoir j'ai pas bien
compris dans vos propos si vous l'avez
évoqué j'ai peut-être pas fait attention
le la demande de remboursement
aujourd'hui
de l'administration elle est motivée
c'est à dire qu'en gros on vous demande
on vous de le courrier que vous avez
reçu
avec un r de ce que j'ai compris à votre
domicile est-ce qu'elle est motivée ou
est-ce que c'est simple c'est voilà il y
a une demande il y a une demande de
remboursement voilà est-ce que vous avez
des éléments factuels alors de quel
montant est-ce qu'elle est motivé merci
pour pour ces questions qui me
permettent de préciser un peu le propos
le courrier qui nous a été transmis par
le cipdr c'est
c'est un contrôle a posteriori d'abord
pour voir si
l'objet de la convention a été gravement
méconnue et substantiellement modifié et
la réalité des prestations
réalisées donc
ils envisagent il n'y a pas de demande
de remboursement formel pour le moment
pour le moment il demande des pièces
justificatives pour contrôler et voir
éventuellement si dans le cadre de notre
convention on a méconnu ou pas les
conditions et envisager
éventuellement un remboursement de tout
ou partie des sommes mais pour l'instant
on considère qu'on est encore au stade
numéro 1 qui est on est au contrôle à
posteriori on n'est pas on n'est pas
encore on est encore loin déjà de
définir s'il y a vraiment matière à un
litige sur ce sur ce sujet là et dans un
deuxième temps si
d'aventure nous on n'y croit pas mais si
d'aventure il y a il y a effectivement
un sujet rentrer dans une discussion sur
le remboursement mais pour nous c'est
encore très très loin c'est encore très
très loin on n'a pas encore les
conclusions de déjà de de votre
commission on n'a pas le rapport de de
l'IGA pour l'instant voilà si vous y
donnez suite ça voudrait dire que vous
reconnaîtriez une offre donc pour
l'instant vous allez vous allez répondre
au courrier qui vous a été adressé et
qui est qui indique simplement une
possibilité à terme
de remboursement sur la question de
entre les membres du bureau
de l'association et les salariés il y a
pas de y a-t-il un lien ou pas est-ce
qu'il y a des salariés membres du bureau
de l'association au membre de
l'association non non le distinguo était
très clair soit on était bénévoles soit
on était salarié
parfait
merci Madame merci Monsieur d'avoir
assisté